екс-президент грузії Михайло Саакашвілі у
ролі українського політика
викладок неоднозначну реакцію він не
поважала що politics іміджем вирішу то
реформатора і кому свого часу вдалося
про обороти корупцію в рузі
у чоловіка спрацюватись і в україні їм шиза
store голи щодо його вигляд вертова
адже популізм у він ніг саакашвілі
роздавши чим мало що вбити сумку
комунікація громадян з держу 100 новими
rectum у саакашвілі відкрив в одесі
піший центр обслуговування громадян за
грузинською зразком центр гавани
мужньо чиновнику бюрократію то
корупцію проте тричі немає розуму
саакашвілі на вигляд ми про закриття
центру через ух волиною верховну раду
це підписаний президентом закони
за його словами відсилання ви там цибулі і
фінансово не і установа та боротьба з
корупцією та контрабанду і за дикою
саакашвілі була ланка але відразу кілька
одіозних фігур новаторським це не титів
порту
через корупцію, то контрабанду звуки cr
формує сіно валдайське ignite і пішов
активістка євромайдану Юлія Марушевська
і найгіршого налякана пішла встежити за
Саакашвілі експерти побоїться що я ж
ставку на таку псину брати буна
одеський ми пнемо збирання ніч
інфраструктура свої вбити анкету лівші
це інфраструктуру для одеситів
саакашвілі супроводжував
купалися ми піар-акція ми я cataplas
що ваня свого кабінету у воді вільному
нам ці для ремонту траса для сари не
життя саня парку їм на самих закуплених
можна владі та пляжах українки у вас
закрили саакашвілі прошу вийшов і
будемо вид-во нового одеського терміналу
аеропорту та відкрита ти за планом вона в
лідку наступна уроку таза порожній це
кілька лукус трейсі в що в умовах
монополії на українську авіа ринку та
дуся в ньому нова поліція про душу настала
одні з пілотних українських областей так
та прес саакашвілі успішно за проти
лануго українсько поліція то правда що
один грузинський реформатор і дуже
сильно подільської у поліції гіорги
лорткіпанідзе тести шов з фасаду через
нього щось блоку Ванєєва працює
скандально по vadimka
це беззаконня це ваша провокація вчіть
тут провокацій all is гірше на і більше
Саакашвілі запам'ятовується українцям своїм
агресивним політичним стилом
діставалося середнього і луценка так де
працював не пішов до
не путіна прокуратура так не роботи
Стівена каррі давно вже так не працює
вам і яценюку як впливають олігархи на
уряд і всередині уряду та
бокову тепер і сам президент став
мішенню крито до саакашвілі грузинської
реформатор то on the корупціонер навіть
що продовжу в цьому і політичну
кар'єру в Україні на думку експертів
wingo туго tomasetto виборі і вчу бути
нову політичну партію перемога України